bonjour et bienvenue pour ce stop
science un peu spéciale puisque ça fait
maintenant depuis 2012 que nous
inventons internet
six ans déjà et très bientôt sept
alors pour fêter ça on s'est offert un
nouveau micro est comme ça fait six ans
de puissance et une vidéo commence à
être franchement dater alors on s'est
dit pourquoi ne pas leur masterisé un
peu l'histoire de les rafraîchir
faites-nous savoir dans les commentaires
si ça vous plaît ce stop science sera
donc consacrée à la toute première vidéo
de la chaîne celle sur les vaches de mer
non non ça c'est un éléphant de mer rien
à voir à part dont non non ça c'est un
beau matin tu le fais exprès ou quoi
massa l'a atteint non ça c'est un
photomontage une vache dans la mer
désolé va taper bon voilà les vases le
maire les seuls et uniques j'ai nommé
les siréniens les sirénia sont de gros
animaux herbivores docile et inoffensive
comprenant les du gong et les lamantins
et qui sont trop souvent négligé par nos
livres de biologie en comparaison de
leurs comparses les cétacés
c'est vrai que dans le genre cas d'école
de maquereaux évolution les cétacés se
pose là pourtant quand on regarde pas
qui situe ses ados issus les plus
anciens c'est assez on a du mal à voir
ce qu'ils ont à voir avec les baleines
moderne il faut être spécialiste alors
qu il ne suffit que d'un coup d'oeil sur
ce sobrarbe et sirène pour y voir la
tête d'un sirénia sur un corps à quatre
pattes de mammifères terrestres
les six gagnants sont donc de si bons
voire même de meilleur exemple
d'adaptation à la vie marine que les
cétacés
il est donc temps qu'un euro rétablisse
la justice la justice donc et se dresse
fièrement en face à la barbarie et
corrige cet affront envers la gente
syrienne commençons par le début
la personne qui a donné son nom au
siréniens n'ai jamais pris la peine
d'expliquer pourquoi il leur avait donné
ce nom
donc c'est pas la peine de nous demander
si le nom si régner à quoi que ce soit à
voir avec les sirènes légendaire la
vérité c'est que les sirénia sont si
faciles à approcher qu'ils ont été
rapidement identifiés pour ce qu'ils
étaient donc ya pas vraiment de mystère
aux alentours et puis les sirènes sont
plus connus pour leurs voix
enchanteresse que pour leur look de
poissons ce qui disqualifie d'emblée
siréniens aux capacités vocales quasi
inexistante
ensuite il ne faut pas confondre sirénia
et c'est assez contrairement cétacés les
sirénia ne mange pas de poisson ils sont
végétariens ils se nourrissent de
zostères une plantes vasculaires
aquatiques et non ce ne sont pas des
algues
des algues on ne s'en remettrait pas à
dire plantes vasculaires aquatique cd
austère point les sirénia ne sont pas
non plus des poissons car bien qu'ils
aient des nageoires les sirénia sont
dotés de poumons ces deux mamelles ce
qui fait d'eux des mammifères marins en
fait les analyses morphologiques et
génétiques indiquent qu'il serait plus
proche des éléphants ses désirs axe
aussi appelé damman ces derniers sont de
petits animaux d'afrique et du
moyen-orient
ayant pour particularité de ressembler
mais très superficiellement à des
marmottes pourtant ce ne sont pas des
rongeurs comme l'essai régnant et les
éléphants ils appartiennent à la famille
des paiements gueulé en effet siréniens
éléphants et irak ce ont tous la
particularité d'avoir des sabots des
sabots alors qu'aucun ne galope et oui
les irak ce sont des grimpeurs les
siréniens âge et les éléphants bas ils
sont trop lourds pour galoper ben alors
ils servent à quoi leurs sabots mais
justement aubanel c'est bien parce que
leurs sabots ne servent à rien qu'ils
sont lundi d'une parenté comines
pourquoi aurait-il des sabots si c'était
pas l'héritage d'un ancêtre commun
partagé une relique laissés là par
l'évolution c'est un peu comme le reste
de que sur lequel vous êtes assis en ce
moment et qui témoigne de notre lointain
passé arboricole les pédoncules ils ont
aussi la particularité d'avoir les eaux
de l'eure main tous bien laminé en trois
rangées comme il faut contrairement à
ceux des autres mammifères qui sont tous
mélangés façon puzzle d'art pillées par
petits bouts façon puzzle
enfin les yeux dépeignant gueulé sont
situées très en avance sur le crâne par
rapport à la rangée dentaire ce
caractère est absolument unique parmi
les mammifères et pour cause puisqu'il
nous ferait ressembler à ça parmi les
pennons gül et les sirénia sont plus
communément rassembler avec les
éléphants au sein d'un sous groupe
appelé territoire ya en effet les
éléphants et les lamantins ont un kirby
filles c'est à dire à deux pointes
alors que le nôtre par exemple n'en a
qu'une encore une caractéristique unique
et sans grand intérêt qui doit avoir
évolué chez un ancêtre commun
les éléphants et les lamantins sont
aussi parmi les rares manie faire à
posséder des mamelles sur le torse et
pas sur le ventre comment non les chats
et les chiens par exemple il est même
possible que l'ancêtre commun des
tétines terre est et amphibies mais pour
ce qui est des éléphants je vous renvoie
vers la vidéo de simples expo néo sur
l'évolution des proboscidiens le lien
est dans la description la famille des
syriens ne compte que deux genres encore
vivants aujourd'hui le dugong et le
lamentin
il est possible de les distinguer par la
forme de leur queue en forme de pelle
chez le lamantin alors qu'elle est de la
même forme que celle des dauphins chez
lui du gong la vente du crâne est aussi
plus recourbé
celle du gong que chez le lamentin et le
lamentin à de belles dents bien
développés qui se renouvelle en tapis
roulant tout au long de la vie alors que
le dugong n'a que des dents relictuelle
c'est assez faible diversité actuelle
n'est que le pâle reflet d'une diversité
passé beaucoup plus foisonnante et il
n'y a pas à remonter bien loin puisqu'il
ya à peine trois siècles vivait encore
un siréniens géant nommé maritime de
stellaire son nom scientifique hydro
malice signifie petite fille de l'eau un
nom assez curieux quand on sait qu'il
s'agit d'un animal de plusieurs tonnes
cet animal vivait aux confins du détroit
de béring il détient le triste record de
l'espèce dans l'intervalle de temps
entre la découverte et l'extraction fut
le plus court de toute l'histoire à
peine 30 ans en effet sitôt découvert
cet animal fut chassé pour sa viande sa
graisse et sabots mais ne nous égarons
pas et si rien donc était autrefois bien
plus diversifiés si aujourd'hui leur
répartition et quand on est aux
tropiques
exception faite du petit spot polaire
correspondant à la défunte treating de
stellaire merci de cette précision et de
rien elle fut autrefois plus étendue
vers le nord certainement sous l'effet
d'un climat occasionnellement plus
chaude sous ces latitudes où les sirénia
proliférer c'est notamment le cas en
france ou dans des gisements comme celui
de castellane ou d'anjou par exemple les
fossiles de siréniens se retrouvent par
dizaines depuis leur apparition après
l'extinction des grands reptiles et en
particulier celle des reptiles marins
une opportunité de se jeter à l'eau de
nombreuses espèces de siréniens aux
formes très différentes sont apparus et
ont prospéré avant de disparaître
notez aussi que cette diversité
foisonnante de siréniens fut à l'époque
une manne pour leurs prédateurs comme
par exemple le célèbre requin géant
megalodon alors d'où viennent les
siréniens comme dit plus tôt les
siréniens descendre certainement de
mammifères terrestres en témoigne leur
possession de sabots sur les pattes et
deux poumons des poumons probablement
l'organe le plus stupide avoir quand on
vit sous l'eau et les dessins
intelligent mes fesses il est donc
possible de prédire que des sirènes ya
quatre pattes ont existé rien qu'en
regardant l'anatomie des cirés neame
moderne simple question de bon sens mais
que disent les fossiles
jusqu'à très récemment l'anatomie du
squelette des plus anciens siréniens
fossiles demeuraient inconnues
c'est par exemple le cas de pro race
tonus le pli primitive des siréniens
fossile connu uniquement par un crâne
trouvé en jamaïque et décrit il ya plus
de cent ans par le terrifiant le
redoutable
ce ricciardo m
[Musique]
vous avez manqué un sens on peut passer
à l'étape suivante
pour info si ce nom vous dit quelque
chose c'est cohen non pas celui là
allah est aussi le célèbre inventeur du
mot dinosaures donc on ne connaissait
pas de sirénia à quatre pattes jusqu'à
ce qu'en 2001 darryl dôme ning découvrez
des crimes le premier sirénia à quatre
pattes connu venu lui aussi tout droit
de jamaïque peso sirène il démontra
ainsi l'évolution des siréniens depuis
des mammifères terrestres et par là même
que la paléontologie peut aussi à sa
manière s'avérer être une science
permettant de faire des prédictions
mais comme toute découverte les
solutions apportent de nouvelles
questions et ici il s'agit d'une
question de taille puisque peso sirène
comme pro grâce au mus les deux plus
anciens siréniens connus viennent de
jamaïque
or pour autant que l'on sache les
paiements gueulé appartiennent aux
grands clubs d afro terriens qui sont
par définition originaires d'afrique
alors qu'est-ce que les siréniens
primitifs riches et en jamaïque si loin
de là où on devrait les trouver
ça reste un mystère néanmoins il nous
est permis de faire une nouvelle
prédiction des recherches plus intensive
dans les roches du début du cénozoïque
d'afrique devrait livrer des fossiles de
siréniens encore plus primitifs pour
l'instant ces roches n'ont pas révélé
tous leurs secrets juste une vertèbre
d'un sirénia proche de pro race tonus et
à petit bout de crâne mais cela suffit à
montrer que des sirènes ya encore
inconnue et très anciens étaient
présents en afrique à cette époque une
science prédit-il jeudi le meilleur
reste donc à découvrir en afrique où
certainement de bien plus beaux fossiles
attendent les paléontologues
ce samsung est terminé merci de l'avoir
suivi pour en savoir plus nous vous
invitons à consulter les sites dont
l'adresse est dans la description en
particulier ne manquez pas l'article
consacré à l'origine des six régna sur
le dino blog le site du musée d'espéraza
et si jamais vous en avez un jour
l'occasion vous pourrez visiter le seul
musée de france consacré aux siréniens
fossiles à castellane en haute provence
ainsi que son gisement magnifiquement
préservé et rendu accessible au public
et bien sûr aller voir la vidéo de
simplex paléo sur l'origine et
l'évolution des éléphants merci à tous
[Musique]